[Musik]
jubel bei der spd sie legt zu und
liefert sich mit ihrem kanzlerkandidaten
olaf scholz ein enges rennen jetzt um
die spitzenposition nach der
bundestagswahl es ist ein spannender
polit abend in deutschland denn der
vorsprung der spd ist dünn knapp
dahinter aber wohl mit einem historisch
schlechten ergebnis und mit langen
gesichtern die cdu csu und ihr
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet diese wahl
wird uns länger beschäftigen ein
feiertag der demokratie guten abend in
allen ergebnisse analysen reaktionen
alles rund um die bundestagswahl in den
kommenden 30 minuten hier und natürlich
vergessen wir auch die beiden
landtagswahlen heute nicht in berlin und
in mecklenburg vorpommern der sport
nachher programm mit katja stresow einen
guten hand die wählerinnen und wähler
haben entschieden nach den
hochrechnungen geht die spd gestärkt aus
der bundestagswahl hervor liegt aktuell
knapp vor cdu/csu die dramatische
verluste hinnehmen mussten die grünen
auf platz drei die fdp liegt vor der afd
die linke könnte unter der fünf prozent
grenze bleiben das werden also soviel
ist schon mal klar hochinteressante
koalitionsgespräche für die aktuellen
details gehen wir jetzt live in unser
wahlstudio nach berlin zu matthias
fornoff guten matthias für eine neue
hochrechnung ja gut nahm wir versuchen
mal eine datenbasis zu legen mit einer
neuen hochrechnung ist es die zweite
heute abend und da sehen wir folgendes
ergebnis hoffentlich gleich da ist es
24,4 prozent für cdu und csu das ist ein
verlust von 8,5 prozentpunkten übrigens
die csu trägt 5% zu diesem ergebnis bei
aus bayern auch weniger als vor vier
jahren die spd 25,6 prozent wäre damit
stärkste partei plus 5,1 punkte die afg
10,3 prozent mit verlusten die fdp 11,6
mit leichten gewinnen die linke bei fünf
prozent sehr auf der kippe ob sie damit
rein kommt oder nicht und recht
deutlichen verlusten
die grünen 14,7 prozent plus 5,8
deutliche gewinne und jetzt schauen wir
mal was das heißt für die sitzverteilung
und da haben wir zwei modelle abhängig
von der frage ob die linken die
fünf-prozent-hürde schaffen oder nicht
was im moment noch unklar ist fangen wir
mal an mit der annahme dass sie drin ist
dann kommen wir bei der cdu/csu auf 202
sitze spd 211 afd 85 fdp 96 linke 41 und
grüne 121 wenn die linke es nicht
schafft in den neuen deutschen bundestag
dann hätte die union 200 sitze die spd
217 a steht 83 fdp 100 und grüne 121
sitze und wir sehen hier an der
gesamtzahl der sitze
721 756 dass dieser bundestag ein rekord
bin ich großer bundestag sein wird so
viel steht schon fest sehr großes
parlament matthias was heißt denn das
jetzt diese mögliche sitzverteilung für
künftige koalitionen
ja das ist die spannende frage die uns
durch den abend begleiten wird stand
jetzt sieht das folgendermaßen aus man
bräuchte 3 179 sitze für die absolute
mehrheit spd und union kämen auf 413
also die große koalition würde
funktionieren
rot grün würde nicht reichen mit 332
schwarz-grün noch deutlicher würde nicht
reichen jetzt sind wir schon bei dreier
bündnissen die ampel spd grüne und fdp
428 das hätte die meisten sitze im
moment spd grüne und linke also
rot-grün-rot 373 also selbst wenn die
linke drin wäre würden sie doch
einigermaßen deutlich es nicht schaffen
eine mehrheit zu haben und jamaika union
grünen und fdp mit 419 auch das würde
reichen das ist der stand 19 uhr
interessante ausgangsbasis für den
weiteren abend matthias für den moment
herzlichen dank die deutschen haben
gewählt und es war ein tag mit zum teil
langen schlangen vor den wahllokalen
zum teil waren deutlich mehr menschen
unterwegs als erwartet zum teil gab es
wie hier in berlin auch erhebliche
probleme
etwa weil wahlzettel fehlten mehr dazu
später in dieser sendung
erst mal hören wir jetzt die reaktionen
aus der politik und gehen dazu zu
bettina schausten bettina ja das ist
aber bevor wir die reaktion hören müssen
wir erst mal gleich live schauen denn
scholz der große wahlgewinner des
heutigen abends ist jetzt vor die basis
vor seine partei getreten und das wollen
wir uns natürlich zunächst mal anhören
ich freue mich so viele hier zu sehen
liebe freunde
[Applaus]
liebe freundinnen freunde
ich freue mich
ich freue mich so viele hier zu sehen
und natürlich freue ich mich über das
wahlergebnis dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes gewählt haben sie
haben entschieden dass die
sozialdemokratische partei bei allen
banken nach oben geht und das ist ein
großer erfolg
[Applaus]
das wird ein langer wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger ihr
kreuz bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
region gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler des landes und
auch stolz sein
so dass jetzt mal die ersten worte des
spd-kanzlerkandidaten der fast das
unglaubliche möglich gemacht hat
jedenfalls wenn man vor ein halbes an
die zeit vor einem halben jahr denkt
hätte ihm das noch niemand zugetraut
jetzt führt er in den hochrechnungen und
wird jetzt sicherlich
regierungsverhandlungen führen zur
bildung einer ampel regierung olaf
scholz später in unserem wahl studie
natürlich ausführlicheres auch der cdu
kanzlerkandidatin unions kanzlerkandidat
hatte sich schon gemeldet an diesem
abend da haben wir auch kurz rein und
natürlich auch die grünen
spitzenkandidaten auch das jetzt kurz
und knapp
das war ein gelungener and spruch das
war eine große aufholjagd ihr habt
großes geleistet die hat nie aufgegeben
und das ist auch mein antrieb das ist
unser antrieb für die zukunft
wir haben auftrag nicht nur für
zukünftige generation sondern man spürt
dieses land braucht erneuerung spürt
einen richtigen aufbruch und vor allen
dingen dieses land braucht eine klima
regierung das ist das ergebnis dieser
bundestagswahl
und dafür
dafür kämpfen wir jetzt weiter mit euch
allen das ist die verantwortung für
unser land robert und ich werden das in
den nächsten tagen gemeinsam dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden und zwar so
wie immer gemeinsam
so dass also die statements der drei
kanzlerkandidaten war es welche frage am
heutigen abend noch nicht beantwortet
ist ist in der tat wer wird der neue
merkel denn sowohl union als auch spd
werden
versuchen eine koalition zu bilden jetzt
beginnen wir den reigen durch die
parteizentralen und wir beginnen bei der
spd in der hochrechnung
25,6 prozent das ist ein plus von mehr
als 5 prozentpunkten im vergleich zu
2017 im willy brandt haus verfolgt den
abend stark unter labbadia
der jubel wir haben ihn gehört
und reist auch gar nicht ab jetzt ist
gerade saskia esken hinter mir auf der
bühne die spd feiert diesen erfolg und
olaf scholz hat aber auch gerade
noch einmal klargemacht dass er dagegen
halten wird gegen das was wir eben von
armin laschet gehören wird dass er also
zwar auch sieht dass das ergebnis nicht
ganz fest steht aber dass er sich um
eine regierungsbildung bemühen wird das
ist hier auch groß mit applaus belohnt
wurden und es wird sehr spannend zu
sehen sein wie sich jetzt beide seiten
und fdp und grüne bemühen werden denn
das ist ja zumindest so weit dass die
zahlen momentan
hergeben das sind das die optionen die
sich momentan sieht
dankeschön chuck und heller wir gehen
weiter zur cdu die union aus cdu csu
kommt in der hochrechnung auf 24 4
prozent das sind deutliche verluste mehr
als acht prozentpunkte im vergleich zu
2017 ein neuer historischer
minusrekord und dennoch will armin
laschet versuchen eine regierung zu
bilden
im konrad adenauer haus ist theo koll ja
wie wird das diskutiert
also das ergebnis wurde er mit schweigen
angenommen angesichts dieses historisch
schlechten ergebnis jubel gab es
allerdings bei den zahlen dass rot grün
rot nicht funktionieren wird
nichtsdestotrotz wird hier
reklamiert dass man eine regierung
bilden möchte und ein ziemliches bei mir
der generalsekretär der cdu ist es dabei
egal wie weit sie hinter der spd liegen
würden na ja das wird jetzt ein ganz
langer wahlabend wir sehen es ist ein
kopf an kopf rennen und am ende geht es
um die frage wer ist in der lage eine
zukunfts koalition zu bilden die die
wichtigen thema also stabilität und
sicherheit aber auch innovation und
klimaschutz
zusammenbringt und das wird sich jetzt
zeigen klar die verluste für uns sind
schmerzlich im vergleich zur letzten
bundestagswahl als wir ganz anders
abgeschnitten haben aber das ist eine
frage und der befehl auch nicht
schönreden innerhalb der partei aber wir
haben immer das credo erst das land dann
die partei und deswegen werden wir
gespräche führen und hat gerade
angekündigt dass er in seinen
sondierungsgesprächen in
koalitionsgesprächen
ganz viel platz für die beiden anderen
dateien geben würde damit die genau das
umsetzen können was sie ihren wählern
versprochen haben das klingt aber nach
einer sehr schwachen position für die
union naja ich finde in dieser zeit in
der wir jetzt leben ist eine wichtige
frage das land zusammenzuhalten und
zusammenzuführen das kann armin laschet
und deswegen einen glückwunsch an die
grünen und auch an die fdp zu diesen
guten ergebnissen zum teil historisch
guten ergebnissen sie haben ja auch
einen auftrag für ihre wählerinnen und
wähler und das respektieren wir als
union und deswegen wollen wir gemeinsam
darüber sprechen ob es die möglichkeit
gibt eine zukunfts koalition zu bilden
noch mal eine klare ansage sie werden
jetzt sondieren für eine jamaika
koalition ja diese option liegt auf dem
tisch wir warten ab wie sich die zahlen
weiter entwickeln nach jetzigem stand
hätte jamaika eine mehrheit eine
zukunfts koalition eben für diese themen
stabilität klimaschutz innovation und
darüber sollte man sprechen ja
herzlichen dank und david zurück zu
bettina schossen dankeschön und da hört
man das werben um die grünen natürlich
schon heraus die grünen kommen in der
letzten hochrechnung auf
14,7 prozent das ist deutlich weniger
als man sich erhofft hatte aber es ist
durchaus das beste ergebnis im bund seit
bestehen der partei patricia wiedemeier
ja da ist ist ein bisschen gespaltene
gefühle heute abend bei den grünen wenn
man es richtig wahrnimmt
ja das kann man so sagen es sind so
gemischte gefühle hier einerseits war
der jubel riesengroß als das ergebnis
für berlin kam denn hier könnte
möglicherweise die
grünen-spitzenkandidatin auch an erster
stelle liegen
natürlich wurde das ergebnis verbessert
8,9 prozent waren es beim letzten mal
aber die rund 20 prozent die die grünen
seit monaten hatten die wurden nicht
erreicht bei mir steht robert habeck
auch spitzenkandidat und
parteivorsitzender ist das wahlergebnis
nicht eher enttäuschend monate lang
lagen sie um die 20 prozent nein
enttäuschend ist das richtige wort wir
haben uns ja deutlich verbessert und
gute chancen stark in die nächste
regierung zu gehen aber klar es ist
nicht das was wir erreichen wollten und
auch das ziel um die einst
kanzlerkandidatur zur erfüllung zu
bringen zu kämpfen das hat nicht
geklappt nächste regierung das stichwort
sowohl armin laschet hat gerade eben
verkündet er will sondieren er möchte
gerne jamaika aber auch olaf scholz wird
sicherlich gespräche führen was wäre
ihre präferenz eben wurde gesagt cleaner
regierung muss es unbedingt sein mit
geben lässt sich das besser
verwirklichen eine präferenz für eine
regierung geht zur zeit passt also das
war ein ziemlich merkwürdiger wahlkampf
wird ganz schön gebirge zwischen durch
die nächste regierung muss aus der
situation das machen und derjenige hat
in der jugend auftrag der eine koalition
anführen kann die antworten gibt die zur
zeit passend dass es unser maßgabe wir
werden sehen wie sich der abend
entwickelt noch sind die relativ gleich
auf aber wir wollen regieren die spd
nieder die gibt es da es gibt die spd
aber wenn es eine ampel würde wäre es
eben nicht rot grün und das heißt das
bündnis müsse eine eigene idee
formulieren ist müsste sich zu einer
eigenen politischen stärke finden aus
sich selbst heraus ein anspruch anmelden
können wenn das gelingt ist es
interessant das gleiche kann aber
theoretisch auch unter der führung der
cdu passieren damit herzlichen dank und
zurück ins wahlstudio ja das sind
ziemlich klare worte also die grünen
legen sich nicht fest werden sondieren
und
schließen nichts aus in beide richtungen
ist der offenheit zu hören so und das
ist die große frage ob das bei der fdp
auch so so wäre die fdp hat sich etwas
verbessert in der hochrechnung bei 11,6
prozent und sie kann jetzt in der tat
mit entscheiden über die künftige
regierungskoalition frank buchwald ist
bei den liberalen
thomas dehler haus ja und da wird dieses
thema sicherlich auch heiß diskutiert
das wird hier heißt diskutiert die fdp
freut sich zum zweiten mal
hintereinander zweistellig und keine
koalition geht ohne die fdp bei mir ist
johannes vogel stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender mit wem wollen sie
sich jetzt als erstes sondieren na ja
für uns geht ja nach der wahl was wir
vor der wahl gesagt haben und wir haben
vor der wahl gesagt wir werben nicht für
koalition sondern wir haben für unsere
konzepte und genau so gilt das auch
jetzt ja ich freue mich erstmal dass wir
aus eigener kraft ohne irgendwelche
taktischen wähler nur überzeugungstäter
uns zum zweiten mal zweistellig gemacht
haben und was dann in die nächsten tage
bringen an gesprächen das muss man dann
sehen erstmals für uns der klare auftrag
dass er das land voranbringen mit
marktwirtschaftlichen überzeugungen mehr
chancengerechtigkeit vor allem der
langfristigen denken bei den großen
herausforderungen rente stabil machen
digitalisierung voranbringen klimaschutz
mit marktwirtschaft darum geht es uns
und danach messen wir auch
koalitionsfrage prima vielen dank so
viel von der fdp zurück zu bedienen ja
auch da hält man sich das offen vielen
dank die af.de da schauen wir jetzt hin
war oppositionsführer im deutschen
bundestag 12,6 prozent beim letzten mal
in der hochrechnung jetzt bei
10,3 also etwas verloren ja damit wurde
das wahlziel verfehlt david geppert
ja hier brandete bei der afg applaus
auch als die negativen ergebnis für die
union an die wand geworfen wurden als
dann aber klar war dass der eigene
banken auch nach unten geht ebbte der
auch ganz schnell wieder ab bei mir
steht die erneuten ko parteichef der fdp
herr leuten er wer trägt dafür die
politische verantwortung sie konnten
offensichtlich nicht von dem schlechten
unions ergebnis profitieren sie hatten
schon gesagt es war ein wahlkampf zu
sehr für die eigene blase wer trägt
dafür politische verantwortung bei ihnen
es ist heute nicht der abend über
persönliche verantwortung zu sprechen es
ist auch noch unter die ergebnisse sind
noch sehr volatil als dürfte feststehen
dass wir nicht dazu gewonnen haben das
müssen wir dann klären wir müssen eine
nachwahlbefragung machen um das auch
empirisch zu
schauen wo kommen wir da raus was waren
die fehler die wir gemacht haben wir
haben uns aber stabilisiert deutlich
zweistellig eine aufwärtsbewegung einer
partei ist nie eine rein lineare
bewegung insofern müssen ein bisschen
die kirche auch im dorf lassen das ist
ja kein großer sieg es ist aber auch
keine fundamentalen niederlagen kein
großer sieg sagte co- parteichef jörg
leuten und damit zurück zu bettina
dankeschön david gebhard wir gehen
weiter zur linken in der hochrechnung 5%
und keinesfalls sicher ob es dabei
bleibt sie ist im bundestag wenn sie es
dann hinein schafft künftig die kleinste
kraft eventuell auch nur mit
direktkandidaten wenn sie dann einziehen
andrea maurer immerhin für den einzug
sollte es reichen jetzt ist die stimmung
vermutlich gedrückt
ja das ist hier tatsächlich eine große
enttäuschung und auch so ne art
schockstarre bei den linken man richtet
sich jetzt eben darauf ein dass es
möglicherweise die oppositionsbank ist
wenn überhaupt denn sollte die partei
unter die fünf-prozent-hürde rutschen
während es eben mindestens drei
direktmandate überhaupt die chance
ermöglichen würden in den bundestag
einzuziehen bei mir ist der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer jan
korte herr korte sie sind bekannt wir
offene und ehrliche worte wie schauen
sie jetzt auch die sozialen das ist ein
leader endlich geschaffen das seinen
kunden alles ergebnis und dass es so
schlecht wird auch nicht nicht für
möglich gehalten und ich hoffe natürlich
dass wir trotzdem noch ago diesen
prozent hürde kommen
konnten zuletzt und trotzdem mit mir
darüber nachdenken was handwerklich
versemmelt in den letzten jahren waren
weniger die letzten wochen waren schon
ein grundproblem dass wir viele sachen
noch viele wahlen niederlagen die der
hatten den einsätzen waren nicht offen
und klar unsere warning letter das muss
jetzt im zweiten auch
ich finde man muss bereitet wenn man
kann ich geld natürlich eine alternative
anzubieten um endlich etwas zu ändern in
diesem land aber offenbar hat das nicht
verfangen und was soll ich da noch mehr
zu sagen also einen regierungsauftrag
sieht ein bisschen anders vielen dank
herr korte das wird hierbei den ein
langer abend und ja es ist tatsächlich
zwischen zittern und hoffen und bangen
zu dir zurück ins studio bettina
dankeschön andrea ein blick noch nach
münchen zu csu die bayerische unions
schwester trägt ihren teil zum unions
ergebnis bei hat dafür auch etwa 5%
zugeliefert man an stefan läufer dass
die verluste allerdings nicht der csu zu
gerechnet werden sondern vermutlich bei
der cdu und armin laschet abgeladen
werden wie ist denn die stimmung in
münchen ja das ist eine ganz
interessante stimmung hier das ist so
eine mischung aus immer wieder jubel und
dann auch verhalteneren jubel aber die
erwartungen sind dann doch am ende
übertroffen worden die erwartungen waren
halt so niedrig dass sind er wird sehr
bescheidene ansprüche gewesen mit denen
man hier in münchen in diesem wahlabend
gegangen ist so dass das jetzt hier
gefühlt jedenfalls kein desaster für die
union oder für die csu geworden es war
mir csu-generalsekretär markus blume zu
blume die csu vollzieht ja an diesem
abend schon eine kleine wende und ist
jetzt doch bereit auch im fall einer
zweitplatzierung zu reden
sondierungsgespräche zu führen was macht
sie zuversichtlich dass die grünen am
ende dabei mitmacht es gibt keine wende
sondern es war einmal klar wir treten
bei dieser bundestagswahl weil wir eine
bürgerliche regierung in diesem land
wollen und dafür ist es notwendig dass
wir als union möglich stark wurden und
es sieht nach diesem kopf an kopf rennen
aus das heißt wir werden erst im laufe
des abends sehen wie stark wir dann
tatsächlich geworden sind aber eines ist
klar ein linksbündnis was viele menschen
in deutschland besorgt hat dass wir das
ganz offenbar nicht geben aber es gibt
eine option für eine bürgerliche
regierung für eine koalition der mitte
der stabilität der modernität zwar dass
markus söder vor allem genannt und dafür
wollen wir schauen dass wir das
realisieren können das wäre ein ziemlich
weiter weg zu den grünen was könnten sie
den bieten ich glaube der abend ist noch
zu früh um jetzt in diese
sondierungsgespräche oder in die
koalitionsverhandlungen einzutreten aber
ich glaube mit diesem stichwort muss es
ja schon gesagt es geht um stabilität in
unsicheren zeiten es geht um die
notwendige modernität die in jedem fall
notwendig ist und ich glaube da bringen
wir als union fiel mit aber
entscheidendes zunächst mal jetzt eben
auch diese option tatsächlich
realisieren zu können dazu muss man erst
mal abwarten wie dann tatsächlich die
wahl ergebnis am ende des abends lauten
aber eines ist klar wir als csu haben
einen ziemlich substanziellen beitrag
auch zu dem unions wahlergebnis
geliefert und wir haben einen guten
endspurt gemeinsam mit der cdu hin
gelegt welche konsequenzen ziehen sie
aus diesem immer noch ja desaströsen
wahlergebnis für die union also auch ein
umfrageergebnis oder jetzt ein
wahlergebnis von 33 prozent da muss mehr
drin sein aber am ende war doch
entscheiden dass wir in den letzten
tagen den letzten wochen beginnend mit
dem csu-parteitag unser potenzial
deutlich besser ausgeschöpft haben und
ich glaube das gibt uns jetzt auch die
notwendige kraft dann auch eine
bürgerliche regierung in deutschland zu
bilden wenn dies möglich ist sagte csu
generalsekretär und damit zurück zu euch
bettina nachbilden dankeschön stefan
leifert und damit ist auch klar dass die
csu offenkundig den durch im gewand
lässt und damit ist das politische
schicksal von armin laschet auch
zunächst einmal gesichert so weit also
zunächst reaktionen von siegern und
verlierern
es bleibt viel diskussionsstoff stoff
und es dürfte eine langwierige
regierungsbildung werden christian
vielen dank bettina und bis gleich es
war ein wahltag mit einigen
auffälligkeiten speziell in berlin sehr
lange schlangen vor den wahllokalen
in einigen bezirken sind sie deshalb
auch nach 18 uhr noch geöffnet gewesen
und probleme mit stimmzetteln mal zu
wenig mal wurden sie vertauscht und als
der kanzlerkandidat der union armin
laschet in aachen seine stimme abgab war
nicht alles so geheim wie es sein sollte
jürgen kehl berichtet ein
spitzenkandidat beim sogenannten uhren
gang das gehört zu den ritualen jedes
wahlsonntags auch heute früh machen
armin laschet scherz noch wo das wetter
dann geht's ab in die wahlkabine
stimmzettel ausfüllen anschließend dann
fototermin das problem die stimmzettel
des ehepaars laschet sind falsch
gefaltet die kreuze für die cdu sind
außen sichtbar ein verstoß gegen das
gebot der geheimen wahl der
bundeswahlleiter meldet sich zu wort ein
bekannter politiker habe wie erwartet
seine eigene partei gewählt eine
wählerbeeinflussung könne darin nicht
gesehen werden und kommt es zu einer
fehlfaltung teil der wahlvorstand einen
neuen stimmzettel aus gelangt der
stimmzettel dennoch in die wahl ohne
kann er nicht mehr aussortiert werden
und ist gültig laschet hat also nicht
geheim aber gültig gewählt
und in berlin gibt es derweil erhebliche
probleme bei der stimmabgabe schlangen
sehr lange schlangen zum blödesten
flughafen zu bauen da kriegt auch keine
wahl hin so sieht es heute mal aus dem
mord und war an einem tag ist einfach
mal des ostens es ging offenbar einiges
schief in der hauptstadt heute
es klingt unglaublich in einigen
wahllokalen sind schon am vormittag die
stimmzettel ausgegangen andere haben
stimmzettel aus den falschen bezirken
geliefert bekommen sodass stimmen für
ungültig erklärt werden mussten und es
dauerte teilweise sehr lange bis die
nachlieferung kam weil zeitgleich hier
in berlin der marathon stattgefunden hat
und sie transporter an straßensperrungen
hängen geblieben sind immerhin einige
wahllokale bleiben auch nach 18 uhr
offen berlin geht in die verlängerung
erwärmt hat gehört in berlin ging es
heute neben der bundestagswahl auch um
die landespolitik um die wahl zum
abgeordnetenhaus und damit um die frage
wer regiert künftig im roten rathaus
eins ist klar jemand neues denn der
bisherige amtsinhaber trat nicht mehr an
derzeit aussichtsreichste kandidatin für
das amt der regierenden bürgermeisterin
sind franziska giffey von der spd und
bettina jarasch von den grünen matthias
wie sehen denn die aktuellen zahlen für
berlin aus zunächst muss man sagen die
bundestagswahl hat beim auszählen
vorfahrt also erst werden die
stammzellen stimmzettel für die
bundestagswahl ausgezählt dann die für
die länder in berlin und mecklenburg
vorpommern
deshalb leben wir was die daten betrifft
erst mal mit der prognose von 18 uhr
weiter und demnach kommt die spd auf 23
prozent mit gewinnen die cdu auf 17
prozent grüne auf 22 prozent linke
14% afd 6,5 und fdp 8 prozent da sehen
wir bei den gewinnern die grünen die
deutlich zuzulegen und die afd verliert
recht deutlich was würde das heißen für
mögliche regierungsbildung in berlin für
den st anna senat 81 sitze für die
absolute mehrheit das amtierende bündnis
von spd grünen und linken käme locker
darüber mit 104 sitzen für rot grün
würde es knapp nicht reichen für schwarz
grün würde es deutlich nicht reichen und
die dreierbündnisse ampel spd grüne fdp
hat eine mehrheit spd cdu und fdp hätten
auch eine nicht ganz so große mehrheit
es gibt also verschiedene optionen
ok danke schön matthias da ist also noch
eine ganze menge musik drin stephan
merseburger ist live für uns in berlin
stefan in guten namen wie sehen denn die
ersten reaktionen aus in der
landespolitik
ja das wird ein richtig spannender abend
du hast es gesagt als richtig musik drin
sicher scheint zu diesem zeitpunkt nur
eins zum ersten mal wird es eine
regierende bürgermeisterin geben in
berlin nur welche franziska giffey von
der spd hat die partei aus dem
umfragetief die wagen mal bei 15 geholt
und ihre mission war das rote rathaus zu
verteidigen spannend ist jetzt gelingt
ihr das und wird sie es auch versuchen
wenn sie nur auf platz zwei landet
bettina jarasch und ihre grünen waren
lange favoriten dann kamen mit dem
bundestrend auch der sinkflug im
sinkflug hier in berlin sie ist
eigentlich auch nicht wirklich bekannt
aber die haben einen beachtlichen
endspurt hingelegt
scheinbar und sie könnte tatsächlich
ihren traum verwirklichen und als erste
grüne bürgermeisterin von berlin werden
in den ersten reaktionen hat natürlich
keine der beiden damen die wahl verloren
gegeben beide hoffen auf das beste das
wird eine spannende und lange nacht hier
in berlin
herzlichen dank stefan und dann gucken
wir zur doppelten war auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern natürlich hier
konnten sich die menschen auch über die
zusammensetzung des neuen landtages im
schweriner schloss abstimmen manuela
schwesig spd ministerpräsidentin sie
will eine zweite amtszeit mit wem sie in
einer koalition regieren will das ließ
sie bis zuletzt offen und auch da gucken
wir zunächst mal auf die zahlen matthias
kann vor schließlich sich denn auf eine
zweite amtszeit berechtigte hoffnungen
machen auch hier haben wir erstmal keine
hochrechnungen sondern die prognose von
18 uhr an schauen sie uns noch mal an
demnach kommt die spd auf 39 prozent ist
klar stärkste partei und gewinnt sehr
deutlich dazu afd 17 prozent mit
verlusten cdu mit größeren verlusten 14
linke 10 prozent grüne 6,5 prozent fdp 6
prozent die beiden letzteren wären also
wieder drin im schweriner landtag wer
könnte da mit wem regieren
die absolute mehrheit hier bei 36 sitzen
die große koalition die derzeit regiert
in schwerin kommt auf 41 das reicht also
die spd mit der linken auch das würde
reichen etwas knapper aber es reicht für
rot grün hingegen sehr knapp nicht da
fehlt ein sitz und spd/grüne mit fdp
würde es ebenfalls schaffen es gibt also
auch hier mehrere optionen darunter aber
zwei zweierbündnisse vielen dank
matthias also fast alles beim alten
fragezeichen wie sind die reaktionen in
schwerin da gehen wir jetzt live hin zu
meinem kollegen bernd mosebach hallo
bernd
hallo ja hinter mir im schloss feiert
die cdu sie hat aber nichts zu feiern
heute mit 14
es ist so dass man selber überrascht war
von dem doch sehr mauen ergebnis mann
hatte vor ort doch den eindruck im
letzten tagen des wahlkampfes das ist
ein bisschen besser laufen könnte und
jetzt ist die frage tatsächlich offen im
wahlkampf die cdu ja gesagt dass sie
bereit wäre weiter mitzuwirken in der
landesregierung das ist jetzt moment
völlig offen ob sie sich nicht
vielleicht in die opposition
zurückziehen denn das war das
schlechteste ergebnis der cdu hier in 30
jahren und die spd hat mächtig aufgeholt
mit fast 39 prozent werbens gesehen
gerade manuela schwesig innerhalb von
vier jahren von einer die ja damals
nicht durch eine wahl hergekommen ist
sondern die nachgefolgt hat erwin
sellering der erkrankt war hat es jetzt
doch auf diesen platz eins geschafft und
das zweitbeste ergebnis so weit ich das
beurteilen kann entwicklung durch
vorpommern damit erreichte in den
letzten 30 jahren und damit ist hier
doch sie weiterhin die
ministerpräsidentin man muss aber auch
leid in schwerin herzlichen dank für
diese eindrücke heute abend ja ein abend
der ganz im zeichen der politik und der
wahl steht das wetter haben wir aber
noch für sie im norden viele wolken im
osten lägen ganzen tag über schauer und
gewitter im süden ist es oft freundlich
das ganze bei höchsttemperaturen von 18
bis 24 grad
so viel im moment von der wahltag screw
der heute redaktion wir danken sie
herzlich für ihr interesse sind
natürlich auch morgen am tag danach
wieder für sie da